High ambitions are noble and important, but
there can also come a point when they become
the sources of terrible trouble and unnecessary
panic. One way of undercutting our perfectionist impulses
was pioneered by
a British psychoanalyst called Donald Winnicott
in the 1950s. Winnicott specialised in relationships
between parents and children. In his clinical
practice, he often met with parents who felt
like failures: perhaps because their children
hadn’t got into the best schools, or because
there were sometimes arguments around the
dinner table or the house wasn’t always
completely tidy. Winnicott’s crucial insight
was that the parents’ agony was coming from
a particular place: excessive hope. Their
despair was a consequences of a cruel and
counterproductive perfectionism. So as to
help them reduce this, Winnicott developed
a charming phrase:
his parents needed to feel that they were "good enough parents",
No child, he insisted, needs
an ideal parent. They just need an OK, pretty
decent, usually well intentioned, sometimes
grumpy but basically reasonable father or
mother. Winnicott wasn’t saying this because
he liked to settle for second-best, but because
he knew, from first hand, the toll exacted by perfectionism
– and realised than in order to remain more
or less sane (which is a pretty big ambition
already) we have to learn not to hate ourselves
for failing to be what no ordinary human being
ever really is anyway. The concept of ‘good
enough’ was invented as an escape from dangerous
ideals. It began in relation to parenthood,
but it can actually be applied across life more generally,
especially around work and love.
A relationship may be ‘good enough’ even while it has
many dark moments. Perhaps at times there’s
little sex and a lot of heavy arguments. Maybe
there are big areas of loneliness and non-communication.
Yet none of this should lead us to feel freakish
or unnaturally unlucky. It can be good enough.
Similarly, a ‘good enough’ job will be
very boring at points, it won’t perfectly
utilise all our merits; we won’t earn a
fortune. But we may make some real friends,
have times of genuine excitement and finish
many days tired but with a sense of true accomplishment.
It takes a good deal of bravery and skill
to keep even a very ordinary life going. To
persevere through the challenges of love,
work and children is quietly heroic. We should
perhaps more often sometimes step back in
order to acknowledge in a non-starry-eyed
but very real way that our lives are good
enough – and that this is, in itself, already
a very grand achievement.
Did you know that the School of Life is actually a place.
Ten places infact, campus' all over the world. From Melbourne to London, Taipei to Istanbul.
With classes and books and lots more. Please click on the link below to explore more.